et enfin de l'amour et donc qui m'a bien
et surtout ma part et dans un instant de
cet article paru dans le magazine public
à skis a assuré que karine le marchand
était pénible avec les équipes et
faussement amicales avec les
agriculteurs alors myriam palomba
rédactrice en chef vous est maintenant
directrice de la rédaction des
divas myriam merci d'avancé c'est pareil
non non c'est pour moi c'est au dessus
et c'est vrai que voilà il ya eu cet
article sur karine le marchand voilà
vous avez défoncé à la fin on l'a
défoncé on a en nous notre mission en
tant que magazine people c'est de
révéler les coulisses de la vie privée
des gens avec tout ce que peuvent en
penser certains tour de table et c'est
également notre rôle de dévoiler les
coulisses d'une émission donc voilà
c'est ce qu'on a fait on est dans notre
rôle maintenant là le droit de réagir
c'est son droit j'ai lu c'est aussi le
droit d'interviewer des agriculteurs et
de faire remonter certaines choses qui
se sont qui se sont passées je voulais
revenir d'ailleurs sur une petite phrase
de jean pascal dans tpm paix ouvert à
tous qui a dit que dans public on disait
un coup oui un coup non et que de toute
façon et avec des conneries non faut
arrêter les gens qui parlent sont des
vrais agriculteurs je ne dévoilerai pas
les sources que certains ne voulaient
pas parler donner leur nom c'est un peu
quand même le droit du journaliste de
préserver ses sources c'est encore un
des droits qui nous reste donc autant en
profiter et puis et puis voilà après
avoir été dans la colonne elle arrive
avec son chauffeur personnel tu toi
comme s'il connaissait les gens depuis
toujours est il qu'il se préparait tout
le monde attend que madame soit prêtre
pendant plus d'une heure sans bouger et
puis quand elle se pointe enfin elle se
regarde dans la caméra et pique une
crise à sa coiffeuse personnelle sa
mèche ne lui convient pas donc à lui dit
de tout recommencer on attend à nouveau
une heure jusqu'à ce qu'elle soit
contente oui ben mes pages maintien
c'est c'est ce que nous on nous a
raconté un agriculteur et qui a été
confirmé par d'autres puisque la
journaliste qui a fait ce papier on a
rencontré plusieurs alors on ne doit
surtout pas lui proposer d'alcool elle
ne veut pas en avoir sous le nez elle ne
mange pas non plus n'importe quoi elle
se commandent ces des menus sans viande
très léger et nous concerne pas les
produits de la ferme centre pour
comprendre bah oui on peut comprendre
c'est son droit mais nous c'est juan on
peut comprendre aussi qu'on raconte sa
valve va chez des agriculteurs
le problème avec l'alcool c'est pas
qu'elle en boivent pas ça c'est son
droit à la wii
on sait que personne voilà c'est pas
parce qu'on va boire une goutte de vin
qu'on est alcoolique donc voilà elle a
une raison personnelle que je ne
pourrais pas dévoiler sur ce plateau
sans s'en être diffamatoires je la
comprends totalement et je la respecte
non là on n'a pas mis la raison dans le
pavé parce que vous savez très bien que
juridiquement il ya certaines choses
qu'on ne peut pas dire c'est son droit
mais bon à interdire à tout le monde de
boire sous ses yeux ça c'est limite je
verrai ya un mot qui va choquer tout le
monde mais la dictature coiffe un schéma
s'est pas fait voilà c'est quand on est
assis que je me confie sur mon
adolescence difficile et sur le fait que
j'ai pensé au suicide à cette époque
elle à cette petite larme à l'oeil et
quand la productrice unis c'est bon
c'est dans la boîte elle se lève et
rigolent et moi j'étais toujours assis
en train de pleurer oui bah oui c'est
moi certains ego bah oui c'est c'est
vrai basse et ça c'est guillaume l'un
des ses agriculteurs l'un des premiers
agriculteurs ont fait le premier
agriculteur homosexuels qu'ils racontent
fin donc donc là et puis ça c'est pour
le coup c'est cette cette citation est
une est quelque chose qui avait déjà été
publié donc faire tout un pataquès un
pur parce que ces publics qui dit ça
alors que ça a été dit par d'autres
magazines dit plus plus sérieux enfin
c'est complètement débile donc voilà
en poussant on vous sent ça voulait
m'aider avoir évolué mais pas du tout
mais je suis également allé quoi l'on
aimé ou pas aimer l essai juste faire l
essai vue de faire son travail wiggins
trouve que ce que dit madame ça se voit
de plus en plus à l'antenne shufu karine
lemarchand l'est de moins en moins
bienveillante avec les candidats là
cette année ils ont rajouté ses
commentaires sur les speed dating elle
est très dure avec tuer les casse hier à
la défoncer une candidate qui s'appelle
nathalie et les iem on comprend rien
quand tu pars on dirait un personnage
donné mon coach et qu'elle n'est pas
très bienveillante et on sent qu'il ya
un énorme décalage entre elles et les
agriculteurs alors il ya quelqu'un qui
me dit karine le marchand n'a jamais eu
une superbe image dans le milieu en off
elle n'est pas super agréable je les ai
vus à plusieurs de camions ce n'est pas
la plus sympa du milieu alors pourtant à
l'antenne on vous a fait une petite
compil c'est vrai car il a l'air bien
sympathique à l'antenne
je me lève pas je suis désolé je peux
pas encore mais il a quand même assez
mignon
super talent vient dormir dans sa main
qui sont tous formidables toi aussi tu
es formidable hans charme des petites
fleurs les beaux yeux bleus aussi
[Musique]
on m'a dit de la concurrence et à trois
quarts et oui
vous êtes tout lumineuse tout souriant
ca fait plaisir
alors faut savoir que ça fait un
pataquès pas possible dans cette partie
puisque même si ça fait 1-1 voilà en a
parlé lors de la conférence dehors d'une
conférence de presse kelly vous dira que
c'est que voit on sait on connaît votre
inimitié pour karine offert ans de
presse on n'était pas habité en voilà
alors alors non en fait c'est pas la
question d'inimitié c'est que je sais
pas si c'est de la diffamation de dire
que c'est vrai que nos maquilleuse et
nos coiffeuse de chez nous nous ont
toujours dit qu'elle avait un
comportement et que ces crabes sur les
tournages et ça je ne sais pas si on
peut le dire mais là si vous pouvez le
dire vous venez de le dire
[Rires]
c'est vrai qu'on nous a toujours dit que
quand elle avait ses fiches balles et
les jeter par terre et que c'était les
instants qui ramassait qu'elle avait un
concert c'est matthieu delormeau
voilà on dit a débattu voulait non alors
à sa décharge il y en a d'autres qui
sont odieuses maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est paix c'est pas la fiq et la
répulsion plus sympathique et du coup
quand on a fait cette émission je me
suis plutôt que d'être que sur des
rumeurs et des machins je vais passer
des coups de fil
les labos voilà une personne travaille
tard édition de boulot en fait
exactement j'aimerais prenez le public
j'entendais des maquilleurs et coiffeurs
qui disent m'enfin bon et voilà et c'est
vrai que les fennecs qui m'a dit sur le
l'émission l'amour est dans le pré il ya
quelques années elle nous a fait une
crise de nerfs en plateau parce qu'on
l'ait va amener du fromage blanc 20% et
qu'elle vient du fromage blanc 0 % sur
le tournage et on a une crise tant en
deux heures bon voila et m'ont dit elle
a beaucoup de talent l'intelligence elle
est souriante mais c'est vrai qu'elle
est caractériel ou alors mais est ce
qu'on peut est ce qu'on peut lui en
vouloir maintenant est ce qu'on s'en
fout pas un peu avant le téléspectateur
à paris c'est à mon sens les accès mais
leur myriam et mathieu qui souvent pensé
me regarde ben ou enfin copains oui pu
enfin le téléspectateur il est il à 11,6
sinon la presse people n'a plus lieu
d'être mais leur démission quand même
dans l'émission quand même ça fait de
très bonnes audiences nous révèle les
coulisses après chacun est libre de
penser ce qu'il veut fin c'est pas parce
que nous on fait un papier que les gens
vont s'arrêter au regard des
laboratoires qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre et
qu'ils ont repris et c'est vrai que
voilà nous voilà on n'est pas vrai on
n'est pas très pote avec karine le
marchand
et on remarque quand même que quand
c'est parce c'est une femme donc tout de
suite les mots de la rive c'est
l'hystérie match à caen c'est un homme
on dit ils exigent il est dur de
nagui
de moi de mon nom mais deux mois gilles
verdez siouplait valérie ya pas de
sexisme dans l'article ya une réalité
qui est objectivement félix est
parfaitement subjectif et aborde son
avenir c'est comme si moi le désir de
maintenir ou non aller c'est moi que je
suis libre je suis là près de moi dans
les solutions version 6 points le
crachoir je vais jamais finir mais folle
et on a très tôt que jeudi haj ali tar
heel merci le problème c'est la fausseté
oui c'est qu'elle est fausse c'est ça
c'est je suis sa part à quel point de du
métier le marchand tout le monde le sait
le dit c'est mieux oui c'est plus un
ballon de [ __ ] de moins que la voilà
bon voilà c'est l'hypocrisie qui est
gênant et elle fait ça et que les
agriculteurs quand elle est dans
incroyable talent elle crie parce que le
micro est pas ouvert ça j'ai eu des
témoignages mais sinon elle est pas
hautaine pascal est contrôlée dans un
lieu clos dixans l'extérieur elle se
prend pour la reine des agriculteurs la
reine de la télévision et c'est vrai
qu'il ya de la suffisance et c'est
extrêmement gênant parce que le
téléspectateur à une image faussée
liquide présente mais c'est vrai il a
belle vous pouvez gagner ça fait que dit
l'article est très bien fait moi j'ai la
même source sur route depuis des mois
c'est vrai non mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ce flingage en règle pardon mais moi
c'est anniversaire et j'ai assisté à
plusieurs années elle n'est pas monde je
ne descends pas parce qu'elle est menée
mais vous êtes encore dit copine arrêté
imposant réaliser notre soif
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti comme ça non mais elle est
aussi un ami parce que je ne défends pas
parce qu'elle est mon ami j'ai signé
norman y avait un certain nombre de
qualités que je me reconnais qu'au fond
[Musique]
sur le tour je suis arrivée elle a
toujours elle est toujours arrivé à
l'heure même quand on se connaissait pas
bien du tout pendant toute une période
je n'aurais pas aimé et j'ai fait les
lui à charge et à décharge
mais j'ai vu qu'elle aime un certain
nombre de qualités que beaucoup
d'agriculteurs lui reconnais je suis
très étonné que vous n'ayez jamais
appelé des gens comme moi et que vous
n'êtes plus seul tort qu'il aime
beaucoup il y aura une bonne quinzaine
mais tu vénères siégeraient parasites si
au ps on y
allait donner la réplique 6 la réponse
des socialistes avec fremantle qui a
parfois été rapportés dans ce type de
rumeur celle à fremantle c'est la boîte
de production nous voulons à nouveau
exprimer notre soutien karine le
marchand a son caractère oui on le sait
mais là une grande sincérité quand elle
à el maleh mais quand elle n'aime pas
elle n'aime pas c'est aussi ce qui fait
qu'elle a tant de succès et qu'elle est
l'animatrice préférée des français
s'expriment parfois un peu trop mais
personne ne peut lui enlever sa
sincérité nicolas pernikoff et non mais
est-ce que moi ma question c'est est ce
que les téléspectateurs ont besoin de le
savoir
est mignon et jean carrière
mais
est plutôt généreuse à l'antenne c'est
ce qu'attend le téléspectateur
aujourd'hui
que nous sommes dans un métier putassier
et j'entends parler de tous les
animateurs de tout le monde deux travers
enfin tout le monde s'en f matthieu
delormeau pour moi
l interview des gens elle prend quand
même ce sont quand même des gens qui
sont dans des situations psychologiques
un peu particulière il ya quand même
quand vous voulez vous êtes devant la
caméra que vous êtes là en mode
alors d'autres côté malien
accusé moi enfin ces voix là et c'est
pas c'est pas des témoignages qu'on a
inventé c'est des vrais témoignages donc
c'est notre rôle de
déblatérer manuel de langue j'ai vu un
animateur et c'est vrai il disait à
cette émission de témoignages et au
moment du générique et dire au revoir il
serrait la main tout le monde est en
fait avant la fin des témoins des
cloches de génériques et s'est acquitté
de l'antenne au pis arrêté il est parti
et rester c'est en fait un nom aux
journalistes et là c'est un truc c'est
ce que je reçois des sms de plein de
journalistes un autre journaliste
jacques arnould fait une fois karine le
marchand à la rentrée du groupe m6 elle
a fait une crise de nerfs pendant trente
minutes contre me karaman qu'à la caméra
n'est dit pas je n'étais jamais assez
haute la réputation est vrai et je
reçois plein de sms c'est pas la
première fois qu'on entend des rumeurs
ça ne m'étonne pas mais
enfin karine le marchand nous on a fait
des demandes d'interviews
et même avant non mais attendez c'est le
premier papier qu'on fait on l'a fait on
a on l'a demandé public ça fait 19 ans
que ça existe elle n'a jamais voulu
abandonner bienvenue chez bon voilà donc
non mais non mais bon à un moment donné
on posait la f1 on a essayé lui donner
la parole elle le fait elle ne veut pas
non plus exprimé dans nos pages donc
après si elle voulait y répondre allez
welcome ya pas il ya aucun souci dans le
mur de huy
sur le fait que le téléspectateur s'en
fiche moi je suis pas du tout d'accord
parce que justement quand on s'attache à
un personnage de la télé on aime bien
aussi savoir back in est cool aussi dans
l'air des policiers je suis un connard
fini dans la ville les chansons
tout à l'heure on parlait de sexisme
même en fait quand c'est un homme on dit
que c'est un connard donc elle bat on
n'a pas des sites et une [ __ ] donc
justement enfin on n'a pas été odieux
avec elle quand c'est un homme on dit
que c'est un connard on lui reproche pas
du tout le chauffeur et tout ça en doute
bien côté quand animateurs une taille
d'état des moyens bachoffer tu prends
pas le maître-autel et belles conditions
et l'apprentissage reproche à faust et
aux reproches de côté je suis le
meilleur ami des gens qui sont associés
vous qui n'avez rien alors qu'en fait
elle gagne 50 mille balles par mois et
qu'elle a rien à [ __ ] de ces gens
gilbert des cyril temps vous lisiez le
communiqué la déclaration de m 6 vous
avez mis votre intonation sur elle a dû
car elle a son caractère on le sait
c'est le coup de pied de l'âne que
j'aimerais même si c'est le condamner de
lannion qu'anthony chat
c'est pas vous qui avez parlé c'est
monsieur guillaume champ alors
journaliste perso j'ai un très mauvais
souvenir de karine depuis de longues
années et s'en était pris à moi en
m'insultant publiquement sur ce seul
motif est journaliste dans un journal
télé on me dit ça c'est vraiment pas les
avaient humiliés publiquement je
démarrais juste ça m'avait sincèrement
touchés gilles verdez oui quand
quelqu'un d'une chaîne dit salah son
caractère ça veut dire que implicitement
ils reconnaissent les débordements reese
essaye de noir et le mais oui ça ça
perdait ça s'appelle de la communication
de crise ils essayent de cadrer nos amis
je vais les dégâts non mais bien dit un
ami à vous en plus à des journalistes
amenés à vous j'ai appelé récemment
karine le marchand pour une interview
elle m'a envoyé chier
les émeutes je n'ai gagné dire genre de
jeu voilà vous disent tout ce qui touche
à 13 ans n'est pas positif même en off
cain les gens qui l'aiment vraiment mais
on venait il ya des agriculteurs qui
n'est vraiment se reconnaître ou des
roquois patate procédé recevoir ces
messieurs mais non même temps et on est
sur l'a1 d'autres a ajouté la saiem
s'engage en règle est erronée on
n'a pas flinguer
publié des recettes en plus ou de la
gorge ouais mais qu'elle met un peu
parce que
cette émission mais on va mourir mais on
donne la parole à des agriculteurs qui
ne sont pas bons en touche et ben à
charge ok si karine lemarchand veut veut
s'exprimer la tuer les endroits c'est le
joindre et beau poser question est-ce
que vous avez essayé de faire la même
chose sur d'autres animateurs pas sur
moi ce cas des gens bayon voilà pouvait
peut-être à aller voir des gens qui sont
venus sur le bateau qui sont pas
contents et faire un article d'ailleurs
non mes joues ou sur d'autres animateurs
de jouissance en préparation l'accord
sur d'autres animateurs oui bien sûr ça
nous on est là pour révéler les
coulisses des émissions et en chansons
matthieu delormeau vous pourriez vous et
moi j'ai plein de trucs à raconter sous
[Applaudissements]
sa vérité qu'elles sont là quelques
années la réputation des animatrices ont
les seins pas qui sont les pas sympa ça
les amis les gens adorent va qu'est ce
qui se dit par exemple sur un acte voit
la culture à nagui bosse passent pas
terrible vous voulez que je me fâche
avec tout le monde mais en même temps je
n'étais pas terrible sur eux sur voila
je sais pas que c'est un lebron à arthur
alors denis brogniart alors au niveau 2
de la façon dont il fonctionne c'est
plutôt plutôt sympa sauf ou alors par
contre avec la presse il est ignoble moi
je me souviens d'un coup de fil que j'ai
reçu de sa part parce que on a on
l'avait passé en maillot de bain et il
se plaisait pas moi qui n'étais pas au
meilleur de sa forme et il est assez
virulent reclus ruquier non j'ai pas de
arthur arthur
voilà
voilà bah je vais pas je vais pas vous
fasse la joue bien attendez je veux pas
c'est ce qui se dit j'ai pas interviewer
des gens là on a vraiment interviewer
des gens qui ont parlé je suis pas là
pour que lorsque des rumeurs par rapport
à ce que tu dis qu'il livre c'est que
les autres il un bas cyril on sait tous
qu'il a quand même du caractère fin va
alors là on se mentir il est extrême
dans les deux sens en syrie mais en
aidant c'est quelqu'un aussi loyal donc
voilà il n'y a pas de soucis mois après
nous en presse people de toute façon
c'est très compliqué parce qu'ils ne
veulent pas d'un côté ils se plaignent
mais en même temps ils veulent pas nous
accorder des interviews quand on essaye
d'avoir des candidats de leur émission
ils veulent re lire les papiers de a à z
et dès qu'il ya un petit truc qui leur
plaît pas faut l'enlever enfin c'est pas
possible de travailler comme ça donc à
un moment moi je veux bien on n'est pas
là pour
pourlécher alors regardez ce qu'il dit
karine le marchand n'est juste pas une
vrai gentil dans le métier c'est ce qui
se dit depuis des années ce n'est pas
l'attaqué mais c'est factuel ben vous
savez très bien que ça sorte parce que
des situations qui sont extrêmement
frustrante pour les gens sur les
tournages en fait vous avez un plateau
vous avez des techniciens des candidats
et qui sont tributaires de l'animateur
sac si l'animateur envie n'est pas sympa
d'engueuler tout le monde va l'émission
est bloquée donc on peut rien dire tout
ça vient hobbesien un comédien mois
karine le marchand là j'avais voulu
venir à mes habitudes invitation à dîner
j'en ai fait qu'un elle a toujours
refusé la grosse tête froide annoncé
refuser sans avoir la banane c'est
produire devant ça va vous sinon
non mais c'est vrai voilà alors ils
sont où c'était toujours les gens à
charger pays type d'interview maintien
est vrai
voilà oui il ya des gens dans les tic
qui abuse un peu de leur pouvoir ça que
l'animateur fait ce qu'il veut si
l'animateur n'a pas envie de venir n'y a
pas d'émission et si longtemps dans si
c'est vrai si elle a tendance à abuser
de son pouvoir d'animatrice puisque sans
elle on peut rien faire sur le tournage
je trouve ça bien que ça sorte et qu'on
dise la vérité faut être sincère et que
vous dit isabelle on va pas faire un
papier pour dire pointent des problèmes
on va dire karine le marchand elle est
sublime génial elle est enceinte et les
sectateurs l'écurie siouplait croyez
vous oui à 62 % non à 37%
m